when Bob DeSimone asked me if I would
introduce quarry today my first thought
was that I shouldn't do it I suspected
that it wouldn't be fair to Cory because
I would say so much by the time i was
done there'd be no time for her to give
a talk um but I said yes and I'll try to
be quick so Cory was born in Virginia
received her BS in biochemistry from the
University of Georgia was a PhD student
with Bob Weinberg and did a postdoc
training with me in 1991 she became a
faculty member at UCSF and then in 2004
moved to the BD Torsten Wiesel professor
at Rockefeller University ok so that was
quick but I'm not going to stop I'll
fill in a few of the details at this
point I first got to know Corey it's
amazing 36 years ago Corey was a TA in
my genetics course and to be six inked
she was a spectacular TA in every regard
the same year nineteen eighty-two she
published her first paper in nature and
in the context of today's event I think
her co-authors are noteworthy because
they included not only Bob Weinberg who
was her supervisor but also at Skolnick
the paper defined the molecular basis of
the activation of the proto-oncogene
rass and rass had been discovered a few
years earlier by at Skolnik and to this
day it is probably it's at the core of
what's probably the best studied and
best understood signal transduction
pathway in cancer biology as a PhD
student Corey made many contributions to
the molecular understanding of cancer
including a landmark paper in which he
cloned the new
oncogene new is the road road and gene
equivalent to what is sometimes called
her to her to is the target of the drug
Herceptin okay Herceptin has basically
revolutionized the treatment for a
particularly aggressive form of breast
cancer Cory joined my lab as a postdoc
in 1987 I think I remember her
application to the Helen hey Whitney
foundation in which she described her
experience at a poultry slaughter house
and explained how that turned her into a
vegetarian okay she got the fellowship
okay as a postdoc Cory began studies of
the C elegans chemosensory system and
she initially focused on soluble
chemicals namely taste but then she
transitioned she guessed that C elegans
has a sense of smell and to pursue that
possibility she brought into the lab
odors that she suspected C elegans might
like okay now to think about this you
have to know that C elegans eats
bacteria that grow on rotting matter
plants and animals ok so the odors that
C elegans might like I would say most of
us in this room would have a different
response to which was also true for herb
a mate who is not terribly fond of these
experiments nonetheless Cory persevered
and she discovered the C elegans indeed
has a sense of smell and she has spent
much of her career building on that
discovery on this morning I looked up
the letter of recommendation I wrote for
Cory when she applied for faculty jobs
first and I ended that letter with the
following sentence in short Cori
Bargmann is a truly remarkable young
investigator and I anticipate that she
will have a brilliant career as an
independent
searcher um in short she is and she has
as a faculty member at UCSF and
Rockefeller Cory has made a series of
landmark discoveries concerning the
relationship amongst genes neurons
neural circuits and behavior for example
she demonstrated that a particular seven
transmembrane protein as the molecular
receptor for specific oderint thereby
arguably proving the hypothesis that
Linda buck and Richard axle had made
previously Richard is here today and I
have to say he must not have wanted Cory
is a competitor today he and Cory are
husband and wife okay Cory also
discovered a molecular mechanism
involved in breaking left right symmetry
and nervous system develop development
and established that this asymmetry is
of behavioral consequence she discovered
that a single mutation in a neuropeptide
gene determines whether animals are
solitary or social feet of feeders a
behavioral difference that later proved
to be a reflection of differential
responses to the level of environmental
oxygen Cory showed that sensory neurons
and code behavioral responses to an odor
through pre-wired neural circuits which
neuro scientists often call preference
maps or label line systems Cory also
showed that all factoria adaptation is a
circuit level phenomenon in which
interneurons feedback on two primary
sensory neurons to alter their
properties and I could go on and on with
the science mccrory is going to do that
in a more succinct way than then I could
ever do I also want to say Cory has made
exceptional contributions not only
through her scientific discoveries but
also through her service to the
scientific community
most notably she co-chaired with Bill
Newsome of Stanford the brain initiative
that was announced by President Obama in
2013 this was an effort with many
complexities scientific and political
and I think that Cory navigated the
issues adroitly and I think this effort
is now greatly benefit benefiting the
neuroscience community Cory is a member
of the Advisory Council to the director
of the NIH a constant loan which I had
the pleasure to overlap with her briefly
in addition Cory has served on many
other advisory groups including the MIT
broad Stanley Center the Simons
Foundation the Cold Spring Harbor lab
and janelia farm of the hard Hughes
Medical Institute she's also on the
scientific review committee of the Jane
coffin child's foundation for
postdoctoral fellowships Cory has
received many honors for her
contributions most notably she received
a breakthrough prize in the life
sciences the first year this prize was
awarded and interestingly the same year
her undergraduate mentor Bob Weinberg
also received a breakthrough prize Cory
has been the recipient of the cavity
prize in neuroscience the nih director's
award the Ben Franklin award of the
franklin institute and and many others
um I could still continue but I've gone
on long enough please welcome Cori
Bargmann
so I'd really like to thank the McGovern
Institute for the honor of receiving the
Skolnick prize there a number of reasons
as bob says that this is really a very
special honor for me most importantly
perhaps that I did train at MIT and to
feel that you kind of come back and made
good and the eyes of your mentors is
really a significant really gives you a
significant sense of accomplishment and
I'm and I'm very happy to do that and
also you know there is that link with
school ed Skolnick himself and you know
you never know who you're going to run
into in your scientific career whether
it's the students you are with when you
were a first year graduate student or
somebody collaborated with and you just
keep running into over and over you
develop a sense of connection to the
community into science as a whole and
and finally it's always good to have an
excuse to visit MIT and it's always
great to talk to the scientists here and
I could easily spend five one-day trips
here visiting with you know having half
hour appointments with a different
faculty and biology and brain and cog
and related areas so I'm delighted for
that reason as well now some of you will
remember that I gave a lecture here
almost exactly one year ago and about
the work that we're doing in the lab to
understand the C elegans nervous system
I'm not here to listen to myself talk
but in honor of those of you who are
sort of hearing me two years in a row i
thought i would do something a little
different and my talk here from what i
usually do which is usually I'm very
focused on whatever the latest data are
and what the story is and communicating
that and today well I what I'll do
instead is I'll try and take a step back
and just address this basic question of
what it is to understand a complete
wiring diagram and how it is what we
feel that we've learned from studying
the wiring diagram of C elegans so i
started my postdoc in 1987 as Bob said
and in 1986 John why
his colleagues published this rather
remarkable paper in which they described
from cyril section electron micrographs
the complete pattern of neural activity
neural connectivity excuse me and the
nervous system of C elegans that links
the 302 neurons together but this is the
pointer and that is rather fetchingly
illustrated in the slide here showing
you know basically trying to communicate
here to you that communicate here that
you know not only do so C elegans has
exactly 302 neurons every single one of
those neurons has a name every single
one of those neurons can be recognized
in each individual of the species it has
a reliable pattern of gene expression it
has a reliable set of connections and
functions in the context of the animal
now you would think that with that
information and having that information
over the past 30 years although i should
say much of that information has really
been acquired on top of this wiring
diagram since then we would really
understand how the behavior of this
animal works and what has happened is
that the connect home as it's called of
C elegans turns out not to be an answer
but rather a question it's it and the
question is how is it that a set of
known connections between a defined set
of neurons give rise to the behavior of
the animal now back when I was at MIT
some of the people like Marvin Minsky
and that sort of artificial intelligence
community that was here at the time got
their hands on the wiring diagram and
were convinced that they would be able
to use some pretty simple computations
to solve the nervous system of the worm
in short order and while these people
are really interesting they would come
to the Horvitz lab and they were fun to
talk to they would tend to go away and
then we would never see them again and
the reason is that it's really not that
simple to read a wiring diagram and so
what I'm going to try and do today is to
express what we think we've learned
about this wiring diagram how we think
it works why we think it was so hard for
us to understand it first I think
there's some things where we just have
the shape of an answer or a hypothesis
about what the answer is and those
things can still be test
but there's some evidence for that so
I'll just sort of start you with the
basic idea and probably the way that we
all thought about it for a long time and
that is the following their sensory
neurons integrating neurons in motor
neurons they're sort of about a third a
third a third of each and then there's
this group of 20 neurons in the pharynx
which have traditionally been ignored in
which I had to paste into this figure
here from a paper on the wiring diagram
and I would say that the dumb thinking
about this diagram is that it is
hierarchical that it is feed forward and
that information is flowing smoothly
from different kinds of sensory inputs
to the behavior of the animal now I
think it is that that idea has truth to
it but I think it's really a ting that
set of assumptions those really given us
a different view of the C elegans
nervous system that i will try and share
with you today which gives us a sense of
it is much more of an integrated unit
showing collective actions and
coordination of activity across large
numbers of neurons and then the second
thing i really want to bring out it in
addition to that idea of coordination is
the idea about how different time scales
are represented in their nervous system
and how it is communicating information
at different at across these different
time scales to generate behavior and I
think that was probably the part of the
story that we were most wrong about when
we first started thinking about the
wiring diagram was that we came to that
with the field as neuroscientists in a
field where neurophysiology had goes
really the dominant way of thinking
about the nervous system and the one
from which we had learned the most about
how the nervous system worked and those
were really systems where people have
thought a lot about things like ion
channels and synapses and action
potentials which in the event C elegans
rarely uses and we're really in these
sort of the timescales really in
milliseconds of the rapid transmission
of information through the system now
the problem with that in C elegans is if
you're trying to use millisecond time
scales by the time you've gotten from
the front to the back of the nervous
system only a few milliseconds have
passed these are really it's a very
shallow nervous system there aren't that
many layers between the neurons and so
what we've come to realize over time is
it there are other
finescale through which information is
flowing through the nervous system in
parallel with these rapid forms of
communication and two of the ones that
I'll really bring out today are those
those timescales of circuit States which
we think maybe sort of mapping
information over slower time scales and
the time scales of neuromodulation which
we think might correspond to something
like motivational state sort or
emotional states we just call them
internal states in the worm and then in
addition on top of that I'm going to
talk about new work we've done to look
at how the nervous system changes over
time using in the mechanisms of learning
and memory so it's these longer time
scales that shape the combination of the
anatomically defined wiring diagram and
the fast transmission of information
that we think provide the intermediate
level that helps us to understand how
the nervous system works so where did we
start so where we started were the
sensory neurons and that has really been
again a dominant idea not only in C
elegans neuroscience starting with Marty
Chaffee in the touch system but also a
mammalian neuroscience I just want to
honor Hubel and Wiesel since I'm here in
Boston and since Torsten Wiesel is my
next-door neighbor and they're really
starting from the sensory input allows
you to understand what the nervous
system is experiencing and therefore
what it might be trying to do and so
starting when I was in Bob Horwitz's lab
under his excellent mentorship using
tools that had recently been developed
by Leon Avery when he was a postdoctoral
fellow in the lab and some methods that
another postdoc named Jim Thomas had
developed I started trying to map out
and then later many other groups mapped
out the functions of different neurons
within C elegans and we got really good
answers from sensory neurons I have to
say so the worm interacts with its
environment in large part by detecting
chemicals from the environment through
its senses of taste and smell it has all
factory organs and it's hat club anthems
that detect a lot of different stimuli
and you can assign functions to them at
a variety of different levels so for
example this in Toronto
in red is called a sh and this term is
responsible for detecting a variety of
different noxious stimuli high
osmolarity acids various toxins also
noxious touch to the nose and then it's
also very closely allied with a set of
responses to those which are escaped
behaviors so the animal will reverse
withdraw from those and then move off in
any direction so both at a sensory level
and at a behavioral level there's a very
clear set of functions you can ascribe
to the sensory neuron and then here's
the other censoring around the one that
I'll return to most today it's an old
facturing battery neuron called a to b c
and this neuron detects a variety of
different volatile organic compounds
over time as Bob mentioned I learn to
focus my research on the more mild and
pleasant smelling organic compounds that
C elegans can detect there's only so
many times your colleagues will put up
with cadaverine in the lab and so we
eventually used things we know that this
neuron detects things like benzaldehyde
butanone isoamyl alcohol in 23 pentane i
own a set of rather Pleasant fruity
odors that are also byproducts of
bacterial metabolism and these molecules
predict to see elegans where it's
bacterial food might be and it leads to
a motor chemotaxis as well as other
undirected forms of food search so these
are very well-defined properties we can
also define these properties in
different dimensions as well so since I
mentioned dimension of time in more
recent experiments in collaboration with
sulcata theory student and Larry
Abbott's lab we have for example looked
at the time frames over which these
different neurons can detect different
kinds of sensory information so this is
a system identification method that's
been widely used in sensory neuroscience
we can see for example from that that
the AWC neuron is capable of following
very rapidly flickering chemical stimuli
and we can map out the time frame of
that detection of these different kinds
of stimuli and it turns out to represent
a time frame that corresponds closely to
the time frame of the
natural movement in sinusoidal movement
and that exactly this property as
demonstrated by Saul and collaboration
with Yvonne shoe and Christine show in
the lab allows C elegans to do a
particular computation allows it to
measure odor gradients with respect to
its own movements and something like an
act of sensing mechanism so that it can
direct itself in the direction of an
odor by matching its own head
oscillations to the odor oscillations
that experiences and then its future
movement in a new direction and the
nociceptive neurons for example have
quite different temporal properties
those neurons integrate different kinds
of noxious stimuli over time and average
it out over time making a decision about
whether to reverse or not so we can
really see a specialization here a
precision and a matching of the neuron
to the behavior of the sensory level
which I think fundamentally mislead us
for a number of years which is to say
it's not wrong it's just a property that
corresponds to what sensory neurons are
doing which is accurately what and
accurately representing information in
the environment that is relevant to the
animal's behavior and we can continue
that theme of accuracy here looking at
how the neurons respond to different
stimuli for example if we give a single
animal a single odor 80 times in a row
once every minute for an hour and a half
we see that every single time that
sensory neuron responds to the to the
odor and gives a nice reliable response
so the sensory neurons are reliable as
well as well behaved and these heat maps
here there's just raster's of individual
responses and here the hot response
shows in fact an activation of this
neuron when the odor is removed which is
illustrated here all very orderly all
very sensible and you can also link this
to what the wiring diagram predicts so
this particular olfactory neuron not
only regulates sinusoidal movement but
regulates reversals in particular it
drives reversals when the odor is
removed because the animal doesn't like
it when an attractive odor is removed
and it is signaling its disapproval by
doing a reorientation and trying to move
in a better direction
and we can follow the C elegans wiring
diagram and this at some level is going
to be the diagram we're going to show
you over and over again representing the
way that we thought of this wiring
diagram the way that most people think
of this wiring diagram first of all we
can't even cope with 302 that's too many
neurons for us so as you can tell we've
cut it down to you know a dozen or so
cell types and then again we think of it
as we draw here as feed-forward is
hierarchical the sensory neuron connects
to a number of neurons which also get
input from a lot of other sensory
neurons and we and everyone else had
been thinking of these as sensory
integration neurons primarily involving
may be collecting and comparing
information from a variety of sensory
neurons then there were a group of
neurons sort of in the middle lightly
undefined functions and then these
connect to a set of neurons that are
directly involved in controlling
behavior in this case this neuron is
called the backward commander on because
it is active in association with and
can't drive reversal behaviors with very
high accuracy so it's really not that
hard to get from the sensory neuron to a
reversal that you can get there by a
direct route you can get there by a
number of indirect routes it all looks
quite logical now I'm just going to
highlight here three of the neurons
along the way because although this way
is the most direct route here this way
through the screen around here called
REM is is actually the strongest route
the one that involves the largest number
of synapses which we uses something like
a surrogate of what might be the
strength of the connection in this
system and so we sort of with all of
this good information about the sensory
neurons about which we knew a lot we
turn to these kinds of downstream
circuits and asked how the sensory
neuron might interact with these
different outputs and here we get a we
got a very different kind of result and
this result is that the interneurons
when we went from the sensory neuron
through the three different interneurons
that resulted in behavior the responses
of those neurons were actually quite
variable so each of these neurons here
is responding to odor shown in grey each
of them is shifting from a hot color in
red to a cold color in
but as you can see that doesn't happen
all the time there's actually a fairly
substantial fraction of times that that
doesn't happen or it happens with the
delay and this variability actually
turns out to correspond pretty closely
with a variability in the behavior so
why the censoring around the response
every time and then behaviors that we
see sometimes and not others and so
there was something that was slipping
between these two points that we found
hard to explain now our understanding of
that came from sort of just going into
the nervous system and trying to observe
different neurons in detail and
recognizing that when we would observe
these three neurons simultaneously they
responded variably but they responded in
a very coherent and correlated way which
is to say almost all the time if one of
the three neurons responded all three of
them responded and in fact their
activity was time locked to each other
so they would then switch on and off in
this kind of organized pattern and this
concept of correlated sort of all our
non responses which you also see here
and that the response went from a pretty
high and somewhat variable level of
activity to really crashing to the floor
turned out to be sorta useful way for us
to recognize that these neurons are not
acting a sort of individual processors
of information that are adding up
information from each synapse
independently but they're acting is some
sort of a collective unit and that
collective unit has an interesting
property which is that these neurons can
respond either to odor or to behavioral
state of the animal these neurons at
every step along this pathway here is
showing the response to odor again this
is really variable there's these big old
error bars here it's the sort of thing
that makes you think you're technically
incompetent but in fact what these
represent or set of neurons that
responded perfectly well and I said of
her neurons that didn't respond at all
and here we have the same neurons
actually responding we're instead of
just looking at the response to odor we
look at what the animal did in response
to the odor stimulus in this case odor
removal here if the animals reversed all
three of these neurons became active and
now the Thunder much smaller error bars
much larger responses and all three of
them responding together so this
suggests that these inner
ants are actually responding not to one
input just from the top but from another
from the bottom can we test that
directly the simplest experiment that
indicates that this is the right way to
think about this is to use up to
genetics to activate neurons at the
bottom of this pathway here to activate
the backward command neuron and look at
what happens to information in the
nervous system and if you activate the
backward commander on you activate that
neuron and you activate these two
supposedly upstream neurons you activate
a neuron which has always been described
as a sensory integration neuron and
drawn as partisan sensory apparatus in
fact embarrassingly you activate it more
efficiently than an olfactory neuron can
activate it so what this indicates is
that information is really flowing
bi-directionally both from sensory
information to output and from the motor
circuit backup there's a bi-directional
information sense of information and the
second recognition from this which was
the work of Andrew gordis a postdoc in
the lab is that these two forms of
information are actually competing to
control the same set of neurons that the
olfactory information has access to it
but is actually fighting against the
supposing information largely from this
guy here is just a troublemaker that
keeps the animal in moving in a
different state depending on the ongoing
state of activity the animal so here's
the first sort of intermediate level of
conclusion that I want to say about this
work is that it makes this set of
experiments this made us really rethink
the wiring diagram but instead of
thinking about it is something that
moves from here to here we suddenly have
to think about some of these things in
between as being interlocked and
interrelated to each other and we have
to think about sensory circuits like the
ones that we've been studying is
actually also being motor circuits and i
would say that in just the past couple
of years this idea has also emerged from
studies of other nervous systems from
very different kinds of experiments for
example my colleague Gabby Mayman on
when he was a postdoc with Mike
Dickinson showed that neurons and flies
that had been characterized for decades
as being responsible for optic flow as
being part of the visual system
are highly responsive to whether the
animal was flying or at rest and Chris
Nilan Mike strikers lab studying mouse
visual cortex showed that neurons in the
visual cortex that showed classical
orientation tuning curves classically
visually to neurons actually showed
hugely different patterns of activity
again when the mouse was resting or
running and subsequent work from to be a
spawn offers lab show that if you put
the mice in the dark these neurons
respond purely to the animals locomotion
state they act as motor neurons in other
words this is not just a question of
gain control of visual stimuli you can
strip visual stimuli away from the
visual cortex and turn it effectively
into a motor cortex and so I think this
idea of coherence and feedback existing
in nervous systems even in what you
might think of as sensory systems exists
here and I could have pulled up other
examples as well of other sorts of
cognitive information like decision
related activity or reward related
activity appearing as early as the
vestibular nucleus one synapse away from
the inner ear so I think this could be a
principle to think about of coherence
now really broadening this is work that
has been done independently in Manuel
simmers lab in Vienna who have been
looking at whole brain calcium imaging
of C elegans I'm using genetically
encoded calcium indicators which we also
use and in this case monitoring
spontaneous activity and down in here
you can see neurons flashing on and off
which actually represent the neurons
that I was showing you there a I BR am
and ABA and you can see that there's a
correlation in their activity that's not
absolute you can also see other kinds of
anti-correlated activity the point of
this is actually that in general
activity seems to go in patterns here
groups of neurons becoming active or not
at different times and manuela flab has
characterized this extensively and more
recently they've also been studies from
arabi Samuels lab across town and aunty
lifers lab at Princeton and everyone has
basically gotten the same result which
is that even in a nervous system with
302 neurons those neurons are largely
function
not independently of one another but
actually in collective states and
collective activity states that recruit
many neurons into high activity States
at a common time and that can be seen
here again in this heat map each row
here is a neuron H excuse me each each
row is a neuron that's right and then
this represents the flow of time over
about a nine minute video recording and
what you can see is that there are
clusters of neurons that are active
together and these include some of the
neurons that I've been telling you about
here and then there are other clusters
of neurons that are for example
anti-correlated with those neurons so
there are multiple patterns of activity
moving through the system at a time and
we think this may be a basic property of
how this nervous system functions and
putting together this rather extensive
analysis that encompasses much more of
the nervous system with the work that I
told you about from Andrew we think that
the sensory system is while it is itself
a very accurate way of gathering
information about the world has a
limited ability to drive behavior and
that what matters in terms of whether a
sensory input gives rise to a behavior
is the state of ongoing activity in a
circuit when the sensory information
arrives that there is ongoing activity
groups of neurons that are
simultaneously active whose state of
activity can be permissive or
non-permissive for the arrival of that
sensory information and I think that
probably is a reasonable perspective to
think on many forms of sensory
information there's certain kinds of
sensory information that are life
threatening that that require an
immediate response but in fact most
forms of sensory information are
relevant under some circumstances and
irrelevant under others and will have
different probabilities of driving the
behavior depending on important things
like the animals state of stress the
animal state of hunger and so forth so
we think that this information may be
more communal and this is a different
way of viewing what the sensory neurons
are trying to do and again what the rest
of the nervous system is trying to do
and I think that this principle
also can be recognized in other very
different systems at different levels of
complexity so for example to move all
the way to a completely different level
of complexity which is the human brain
studies of human brain activity ongoing
brain activity independent of sensory
stimuli have indicated that the patterns
of blood flow have sort of large-scale
coordinated slow activity that identify
different kinds of networks within the
brain so these networks have names like
the default network or the dorsal
attention network or the visual network
where different regions of the brain
will receive apparently higher levels of
blood flow on some sort of a timing that
appears independent of the ongoing rapid
sensory information that a human is
proceeding so here is the time frame of
such blood flow signals within the human
visual cortex you can see that it's
taking place over a time frame of 10
seconds or so extraordinarily slow time
by the time frame again of channels and
synapses and here's an experiment from
David Hebrews lab at NYU looking at the
ability of humans to detect very weak
visual stimuli at the threshold of
detectability relative to the amplitude
of this blood flow signal in the visual
cortex what you can see is the
spontaneous signal dictates how
accurately or how well the human is
going to be able to detect the signal
with tremendous accuracy and so what
this suggests is that very similarly to
what we see in the worm that really the
state of the circuit when the sensory
information arrives has a major
influence on whether that sensory
information is assimilated into the
nervous system and it's the behavior and
cognition in this case of the individual
so what so what I told you is that there
are circuits that they have different
states of activity the states of
activity we believe are developing over
time frames of seconds and tens of
seconds from the measurements that we
and others have made looking at both
free moving animals and restrained
animals and that these sort of seven
long
times of activity represent such a gate
or a preference for different kinds of
sensory information coming in and
modifying behavior now one of the ways
of thinking about this is that this is
also is that what we've what I've told
you is that this is a variable that this
the circuits are variable that whether
or not you get a behavior out of this is
variable and or unreliable and they're
different ways of thinking about
variability and the roles of variability
and behavior there are actually good
reasons that generating variability and
behavior is a good way to solve a
problem in an environment that is
somewhat noisy and unpredictable or
where the value of a stimulus is not
itself predictable but there are other
good ways of thinking about variability
as well and one of them is that
variability is a really important
substrate for learning that by its
nature if the nervous system is going to
do something different it's going to
have to generate some kind of
variability to allow it to do something
different and that's most striking and
trial and error learning trial and error
learning implies that you have to try
things that you have to generate
variability from which you then select a
reasonable outcome so um the really the
best learning circuit I think where this
idea variability and learning has been
represented is in the songbird and so on
learning your colleague Michael fee has
been one of the important people and
characterizing these circuits and what
I'd like to tell you know is that this
circuit and C elegans that I've been
describing as a sensory motor circuit
incorporating both sensory and motor
information is also a learning circuit
that with embedded within this system
are mechanisms that allow the behavior
to change over time so the behavior the
learning behavior first of all in order
C elegans is is not a complex organism
there are things that's going to learn
things that it's not going to learn and
the person who figured out how to teach
the elegans the best in in the olfactory
system was you and John who is now a
professor at Harvard in the OEB
Department who realized about 10 years
ago that C elegans has an environment
that includes both healthful bacteria
that are neutral
to the animal and pathogenic bacteria
that can kill the animal and that really
this might represent an important thing
for the animal to learn for it to
survive I should say that Dennis Kim
who's here at MIT was one of the first
people to really study pathogenesis and
the United mune system of C elegans as a
mechanism of understanding its
physiology that's been a very rich body
of work and on the recognition of that
idea that pathogenesis was important in
the life cycle was an important trigger
for us to study the idea that pathogens
would also be important learning signals
for the animal so many of you will know
that condition taste aversion is one of
the strongest forms of learning in any
animal eating something that makes you
sick will lead to a strong aversion to
that substance in the future and what
Jung Jung showed initially and as as a
postdoc has developed extensively since
then is that training an animal exposing
an hours with pathogenic bacteria even
if you clear the infection and the
animals perfectly healthy afterwards
will lead to a memory and an avoidance
of the odor of that bacteria so Jin Jin
a current graduate student in the lab
returned to that paradigm recently to
wonder what kinds of learning C elegans
could show and how long those could last
now the original form of learning that
Young had characterized lasts between 12
and 24 hours which is a pretty good
amount of time for an animal that only
lives for three weeks but shin thought
about the fact that in many animals
early learning is particularly strong
and long lasting at least strongest
memories and so she really did the
learning paradigm that Young had
developed I'm to try to use this kind of
early learning and see if C elegans had
that quality as well and so and she
found that indeed that is the case so
that if she took animals and immediately
after hatching exposed them to this
pathogenic bacteria and then cleared the
bacteria with antibiotics coddled them
let them grow up in myself Oh bacteria
until they were adults and then proposed
the same choice to them these adults
maintain the aversive memory of the
bacteria that experienced immediately
after hatching we're calling this
bacterial imprinting imprinted memory
just to sort of reflect the idea of
behavioural imprinting is something that
happens very early in life forms
long lasting memory and is potentially
ethological e or ecologically important
to the animal we think this is a real
problem that C elegans has to solve and
importantly the magnitude of this change
after training which is shown here so
what we tend to do we're kind of on a
kick where we want to show like all the
data so this is like every single assay
done over a several month period of
naive animals and of imprinted animals
the bars actually represent the name and
something close to the standard error by
the time you're done but i'll be showing
these big wide bars and actually the
effect is quite strong and in fact the
effect of this behavior it's as strong a
memory in the adult as in animals
immediately after training as adults so
this is really a very robust form of
memory by the standards of this animal
the number of cells are changing about
80 neurons get added between the l1 and
the adult most of those are in the motor
system and seem to be just about
mobilizing a larger animal and to the
best of our knowledge they're not
critically involved but we haven't
tested them all yet either and so this
here is just to show that this one of
the other criteria that makes us think
that this is imprinting like is that if
there is a particular time at which the
animal can learn this and not other
times so if we train them as for stage
larvae they remember as adults that's
the positive number but if we train them
a second stage larvae or any stage in
between they forget and so by adults
that response has gone all the way back
down to baseline and here are adults
again immediately after training so
there seems to be some sort of a
critical period a specialized period in
which learning can occur and then the
other thing about this behavior is it
appears to be associated it appears to
be selective for the bacteria that they
experienced they don't avoid any toxic
bacteria so for example if we train them
on two different toxic bacteria here
again let them recover let them grow up
in and test them as adults they only
report this learning to the bacteria of
training and actually show either no
response or even a
owner opposite response to the second
bacteria so it seems to have a selective
time of action and an associated
response that looks like it's that looks
like it's in a formative form of
learning for the animal so how does this
work jung jung slab has gone to a lot of
effort to map out the learning circuits
for adult pathogen learning in C elegans
and shin was really lucky and that she
was able to coast along on a lot of
those studies that young slap had done
including an important one published in
to run a few years ago to identify
sensory neurons and interneurons in a
circuit that were required for adult
learning what Shin found when she looked
at these circuits is that the circuits
for imprinting in the l1 overlapped
partly but not completely with those
required for adult learning so even
though there were differences in the
duration of the memory there was a lot
of overlap at the level of neural
circuits sensory inputs and processing
information for these two different
kinds of memory there are some
differences between them that are
informative and important for example
there's a greater reliance on certain
neurons that are much more important for
imprinting than they are for adult
memory but I'm one of the conclusions
these things were not as different as we
might have thought when are the
different neurons required one of the
nice things about having a memory that
forms in the first stage and performance
a choice s that you can do the adult is
you can try and separate out what's
required for learning what's required
for maintaining the memory and what's
required for performance and shin
silence neurons at different times in
development using a chemical genetic
strategy based on a histamine gated
chloride channel with that we can use to
silence neurons using a transmitter that
C elegans does not use and then mapped
out when these different neurons were
required where they required during
training or were they require during
choice and what she found is that
they're different neurons that are
selectively required the neurons
downstream of the sensory neurons we're
either required during learning or
required during retrieval and not during
both there was a clean separation of the
neurons within this function
so one of these neurons here is the
neuron that we've been thinking about
quite a bit as the neuron that generates
variability in olfactory responses that
neuron here's our a.m. it seems to be
required during learning and so shun
Dobin a little more deeply here to try
to understand what REM was doing and one
of the things she did was to examine the
neurotransmitter that is made by REM i
should say one of the neurotransmitters
made by our IM which is a biogenic amine
called tyramine and it turns out that
with animals lacking tyramine or lacking
timing specifically in RM and not in any
other location are defective in learning
so this neurotransmitter here appears to
be a key part of the signal that is
required for learning in these animals
and you can restore this response to
these animals simply by supplying
exogenous tyranny but only if you do it
during the time of learning during
imprinting not if you do it later in
growth or during the assay so this seems
to be a signal that is really sort of
temporarily and spatially restricted to
the time of the learning now um knowing
what that single is for learning
shouldn't just asked where it was
detected she identified a number of
receptors required for learning but only
one of them was specifically required
for imprinting for the formation of a
very long lasting memory and that one
receptor which is a g-protein coupled
receptor is required in one of the
neurons required for memory retrieval so
this molecular pathway bridges memory
formation on the one hand and memory
retrieval on the other hand through
under a transmitter receptor interaction
so what can we say about this when we
look at this pathway it actually reminds
us of learning pathways in a number of
different organisms that in that
different kinds of physiological
learning often involve a separation of
functions and memory formation and
memory retrieval and two examples would
include the drosophila mushroom body for
example where certain neurons that make
a modulator dopamine are required for
the formation of the memory but not for
the retrieval of the memory later
dopamine is and dopamine is a biogenic
amine as is tyramine perhaps there's
some similarity there
the roles of these is teaching or
learning signals and then another
example goes back to the songbird where
distinct areas are required to learn the
song but not for the retrieval or
performance of the adult song and
interestingly in songbird these areas
that are required for learning are also
areas that generate variability in the
song response and so we think that there
might be some sort of a relationship
here between this idea of variability
and flexibility in generating different
learn bakers we're currently very
excited about trying to understand more
about how this learning happens part of
that just involves returning to the
circuits and understanding how they
respond to bacteria and how they respond
to different how they respond after
learning so for example one of the
things that we've done is to look at the
sensory neurons the whole not just one
sensory neuron time but the whole group
of sensory neurons in the animals nose
as they respond to different kinds of
bacteria and what we find when we do
this is that the sensory neurons
actually it's not just one or two
sensory neurons that respond it's almost
the entire group of sensory neurons are
aware of the appearance of these
different bacterial species so here the
darkslides is a cluster of neurons here
that come on and then here in the gray a
cluster of neurons here again dark these
neurons come on the swath of neurons
here lighter gray these neurons here so
we're sort of seeing a that this is
really looks like some sort of a
population of neural activity is
generating a signal about these
different bacterial stimuli now this is
an alternation between two bacterial
stimuli it turns out that this is all so
different from giving the one at a time
which has some interesting implications
for coding and we could follow that
information in part through the circuit
so for example shouldn'ts identified one
neuron that based that contracts very
closely to whether the animal is showing
a memory or not showing a memory of
imprinting that's this neuron riaa it's
one of the memory retrieval neurons and
it actually changes the sign of response
to the pathogenic bacteria after the
training from a positive to a negative
response now we're happy about this but
at some level we know that it's not a
complete description of what's going on
because to some level we know that to
understand this we're really going to
have to return to this whole network of
neurons that I told you about earlier
and look at the groups of them that are
active at different times in fact one of
the things that Shin found is that while
this neuron changes after learning um so
do these other neurons actually they
change in different ways sometimes more
subtle we can separate them from the
memory but it's clear that we're going
to need to look at this as a whole and
not just one neuron at a time to
understand the process of learning and
memory but the conclusion of this part
of the talk is really that that I told
you about a sensory circuit that then
became a sensory motor circuit and now
it's yet a third circuit it's a learning
circuit with learning with memory
learning functions and retrieval
functions embedded within the same group
of neurons that are involved in
generating the basal behavior in other
words that each of the circuits is
really many circuits the last thing I
want to tell you about these C elegans
behaviors is another way in which
behavior can change over time tyramine
is in a way is a really good the
learning signal that i told you about is
actually a good transition to this when
we study the nervous system of C elegans
or many other animals we really focus on
fast transition of information but as we
study problems like learning or as we
study different kinds of emotional or
motivation States we also discovered
that there are other ways in which
information is transmitted across the
nervous system and those ways often
involve other classes of molecules and
other classes of receptors for those
molecules superimposed upon the
classical electrical activity of the
nervous system in humans these module
ettore systems are the targets for most
drugs of abuse and most psychiatric and
neurological drugs so we know that they
are important for our own behavioral
perception as well as those of animals
and they include things like dopamine
serotonin orexin and opioids so um these
molecules are prominent in all nervous
systems they may actually be a little
more ancient to the nervous system than
fast transmission actually based on
evolutionary history of some of these
things so they're their present and
nervous systems across evolution and in
some cases they may even have
actions that are related across
evolution one of the most famous of the
modulators for example is oxytocin and
the related peptide nerve a suppressant
which are molecules known for their
effects on social behaviors mating
behaviors aggressive and mother bombing
behaviors of mammals as sort of
symbolized here by the relationship in
this case of the mother and father of
all with their many pups now this is one
of the g-protein coupled receptor
systems it's important in mammals it's
clearly important in a variety of
different reproductive behaviour and
it's C elegans there is an orthologue of
that peptide there are orthologs of two
of its receptors and these molecules
have a selective function in organizing
reproductive behaviour in C elegans
they're important for the timing and the
coordination of different male mating
behaviors and so without going into a
lot of detail about this what this
suggests is that there are important
roles of behavioral neuropeptides in
mediating what you might think of as
long-lasting internal States the things
like reproductive behaviors are special
behaviors they're privileged and they're
represented not just by Anatomy but
actually by neuro chemistry that helps
to rewire neural circuits for their
functions and that in fact this
particular one appears to be used in
reproductive behaviors across all the
major branches of by latarian animals
whether that's a conservator a
conversion [ __ ] function I think we have
to take on the soft side but certainly
the idea that this kind of a system
these g-protein coupled systems are
being used for slow modulation and for
longer lasting behavioral States is a
powerful and useful one so G
protein-coupled receptors can operate on
time scale of seconds or minutes or
hours we studied some of these when
Steve Lobel was a postdoc in the
laboratory and he's now your colleague
here at MIT and he was looking at it
spontaneous internal States generated by
the animal that could last on the order
of several minutes first described by by
Manabi Fujiwara that are called roaming
and dwelling they just represents
spontaneous locomotion States apparently
unrelated to external sensory stimuli
and a one-for-one way but rather
just representing the animals organize a
organized response to its environment so
there's an active state called a roaming
state which involves a high degree of
speed and a low rate of reversal and a
quiet state called the dwelling state
which represents a high level of
reversal and a low rate of speed when
Steve was in the lab he asked what
neural systems controlled this
long-lasting form of behavior and he
identified two neuromodulators that have
really important roles in this behavior
and reciprocal roles one of them
serotonin is another one of these
classical bio means that we're all
familiar with and it appears to be
involved in lengthening dwelling States
it promotes a sort of quiet or relaxed
behaviour whereas the second one is a
neuropeptide PDF and has the opposite
effect it seems to be required to
lengthen roaming states the more active
behaviors so Steve very carefully mapped
out the roles of these mantra laterz by
identifying the cells that made each
modulator and the self that responded to
each modulator that made the receptor
for each modulator and which of those
were required for each of these
different behaviors and what he found
were a variety of cells that make the
neuromodulators of different sorts and a
variety of cells that express their
receptors and the important thing to say
about these modulator zeeeee is that the
unconnected he discovered here were
literally completely independent of a
classical wiring diagram of C elegans
they had nothing to do with neurons that
were anatomically connected by synapses
so on listening on here is an element of
the Ferengi lurve asst system the one I
told you that everybody just kind of
leaves off their diagrams this is a
motor neuron in the middle of the body
and yet they are coming back and feeding
long the neurons within the wiring
diagram including sensory neurons as
well as inter neurons that were involved
in those foraging behaviour I told you
about earlier so this is a completely
different logic laid on top of the logic
of the olfactory neurons and so this is
another example really in which each
circuit as many circuits because we can
take that knowledge about neurological
so realize that they're being made
completely outside the circuit but they
are remodeling the roles of the
different neurons within the circuit and
they are actually changing the way that
information flows to lead to very large
scale coherent changes in behavioral
state this idea of large-scale and
longer lasting changes in behavioral
state has really become very alluring to
us we've been trying to think about
behavior now over time scales ranging to
the life of the animal and I'll just
close on an experiment that we think is
kind of hilarious in the lab this is
known as the black box experiment
because I'm shy Stern a postdoc in the
lab has made a black box which is
literally black and it is temperature
and environmental control and control
from vibration and enables them to
monitor the behavior of animals over
their entire lifetime to try to look at
the behavior of individual animals at
different developmental stages compare
them to each other compare different
genotypes compare different conditions
and so on this takes so much computer
time that Rockefeller IT came over to my
lab thinking that we were running
spambots out of the lab I'm very proud
of this and here's just an example of a
very simplified summary of some of the
data from this kind of experiment
showing the speed the average ground
speed of animals over a 60 hour period
when they're little they move slowly
when they're big they move faster but
here's just something the speed here
represents essentially something like a
roaming state but this is a roaming
state it's actually a constellation of
roaming states that for about this five
hour period here the animals were
roaming almost all the time this animal
I should say was roaming almost all the
time and so we can see much longer term
patterns in this individuals behavior
even then we were able to see before and
one of the things that we've done here
is to just sort of start to recognize
that there are in fact patterns that you
can see over the behavior of the entire
lifetime of the animal so here we
normalized the speed on the heat map so
you didn't it isn't overwhelming by the
fact that the animal was small and just
looked over its entire lifetime and what
you can see is that for example in each
stage of the larvae it's more active
early in the stage than later and then
in the adult there's a little brief
burst of activity immediately after a
mold and
wider period and then a more active
period but we can only see by looking at
very many animals at once and just in
terms of thinking about these
longer-term kinds of behavior here too
we're starting to ask what the rules are
that determine what how behavior occurs
at different times and the first systems
we looked at were the modulatory systems
and they're these I think this would be
a fruitful avenue to think about
different age specific stage specific or
environmental specific organizations a
very long lasting behaviors in this case
over days so for example and this is a
secreted peptide and these animals seem
pretty normal when they're young but
they become very quiet later in life
here the serotonin guys serotonin guys
are faster which is what the red color
means because they're roaming more at
all stages in life but you can see that
they preserve the same structured
behavior over time they aren't affecting
this very long term structure behavior
they're affecting shorter trip
structures within that and then whereas
this other neuromodulator here for
example seems to have more of an effect
on behavioral structure as well as
affecting behavioral state so we think
that these will serve as ways for us of
examining behavior over larger scales
and this is my summary of how we're
thinking about the nervous system right
now we think that the nervous system the
wiring diagram of C elegans represents
not a set of instructions but a set of
options that there are many connections
between these neurons that these
connections can vary in their strength
or their dynamics based on a variety of
different stimuli sensory input into the
circuit will tend to be accurate
although it is itself subject to some
forms of regulation and then the
composition and dynamics within the
circuit which are really being made
collectively by neurons within the
circuit we're going to determine the
outcome in the behavior of the animal
this yellow cloud here in the back is
meant to indicate not only that these
are acting together but also that
information comes into the circuits from
other sources from sources like
neuromodulators which can reshape these
circuits in ways that we still are
interested in understanding and that
Steve himself will be understanding will
be elucidating as laboratory here
and really the final conclusion is that
is that what this represents is that
this highly interconnected highly
flexible nervous system is really a
single circuit that is many circuits and
that our own highly interconnected
highly flexible nervous systems are also
very likely to represent not one set of
terminus tick circuits but many circuits
which can be deployed in different ways
under different circumstances and with
that i will show you some of the people
whose work I talked about today the work
on variability was the work of Andrew
gordis the work on learning was the work
of shin shin and here is T flow go here
at MIT who did the work on who really
established the work on neuromodulators
in the lab thank you